[Music]
stockton is with us in phoenix arizona
hey stockton welcome to the ramsey show
good afternoon um i graduated graduate
school
a year ago with two hundred thousand
dollar student debt at seven percent
my question is
the recommendation is to get out of debt
except for a home the home debt is okay
what if my student loans is as much as a
home would cost is the recommendation to
still
pay off the student loans renting during
that time and if so that'll be
10 plus years
what's your graduate degree in
i'm a chiropractor
okay
and so what are you going to be making
uh i just started a job here in phoenix
85 000 a year
okay and so you you plan to pay 15 000 a
year on the student loans
yes
well that sucks
yeah
that's pretty lame you ought to pay a
lot more than 15 000 if you're making 80
and you should be making more than 80
as your chiropractic career grows would
you agree with me
yeah the hope is definitely to make more
eventually um as i grow in the company
and whatnot the other issue what did you
make but the year before you graduated
what was your income
fifty thousand um associates in
chiropractic don't can be taken
advantage of and i was last year so i
didn't make very good money last year
yeah okay
so what if you lived on 35 000
and put the rest of it towards the
student loan debt
yeah um that was one of the reasons why
we postponed getting a home is is to
hopefully throw more money at the
student loans the only issue is to live
in a rental home where my wife and our
kids feel comfortable walking the street
our rental is 1600 a month and that
doesn't include the administration fees
the hoa fees and other fees associated
with
the renting so
that's something that i struggle with is
being able to throw all my money at
student loans yet my rental i feel like
is taking more money than it should i'll
tell you as as a homeowner it's very
expensive and i'm not talking about the
mortgage payment versus the rent payment
i'm talking about home ownership in
general so if you can't afford to rent
you definitely can't afford to be a
homeowner and so what i want you to do
is focus on these student loans first i
want you to buy a house i want you to
have that american dream but as we talk
about in the documentary student loans
are killing that dream because you've
got this bear of a payment in your life
and you've got a great income it's going
to continue to go up and like dave
saying this thing's gone three and three
to four years from now
stockton here's the thing
you have two choices you can go the way
that you're you're trying to your
emotions are taking you where you're
justifying this and you're figuring out
a way that it takes forever and so you
go ahead and buy a house and now you've
got a house payment and you've got the
cost of home ownership that georgia's
talking about and your career will move
along and it will take you 10 years to
get out of that or more
if you go that route or you can do the
thing that we have taught and many many
chiropractors have done what i teach and
they roll up their sleeves and they say
not today i'm going to engage in a
different
treatment program for the patient
i'm going to roll up my sleeves we're
going to do nothing around this house
we're not going to do anything except
get out of debt we're going to clean up
this mess so that as my career grows i
get to actually keep the freaking money
instead of sending it all to sallie mae
navient or maximus
so uh
this is going to be too much fun i'm
looking forward to the next decade of
this well and so uh yeah the uh uh yeah
you but right now the the state of mind
you're in you're gonna be in debt a long
time
because you bought the lie that you're
stuck and you bought the lie that you
might as well just keep this like it's a
freaking backache or you can do the i
just told a chiropractor like that guy
just said that i did that on purpose
that was a metaphor that he would
understand and so yeah the uh i hope so
you you're going to either engage in the
extreme measures
to get the extreme results or you're
going to be normal
and i sound like you talking to one of
your patients
with the treatment program you put in so
you got to decide
physician heal thyself